c'est toujours la même technique entre
guillemets on procède exactement comme
les cyber patrouilleurs de la police ou
de la gendarmerie
une fois ces enfants virtuel mis en
ligne qui respecte un cadre juridique
strict on est contacté par ces
prédateurs sexuels et ce sont les fils
en fait les conversations peuvent durer
alors plusieurs semaines or noir
ça dépend des profils et une fois on a
un dossier constitué en l'hérault on le
remet au lait ou aux autorités les
autorités en france disent que vous
n'agissez pas dans un cadre légal que
vous êtes hors la loi ça vous le
contester aujourd'hui c'est un site un
mensonge un mensonge
c'est un mensonge ridicule en fait si
nos méthodes et est illégal si nos
pratiques n'étaient si nos éléments
n'étaient pas recevables en aucun cas
nous n'aurions pu permettre à tata
d'arrestations à travers la france et le
canada
nous sommes déjà à l'origine de deux
condamnations
si nos éléments étaient irrecevables si
nous étions en dehors du cadre
il y aurait vice de procédure donc les
autorités françaises au jour
d'aujourd'hui menthe
il faut savoir que après un grand
documentaire de france 2 sur notre
travail
l'un des plus hauts responsables de la
police l'a reconnu lui-même qu'il n'ya
aucun texte de loi qui interdise ces
pratiques ainsi lilhac trois grands axes
fondamentaux à respecter qui va du choix
des photos à l'incitation et au respect
de la vie privée si vous respectez ces
trois grands axes majeurs
vous êtes dans le cadre juridique ces
éléments sont recevables
aux yeux de la justice nous l'avons
encore prouvé ce week-end ce travail de
l'ombre de citoyens est ce qu'il va se
développer on a seulement 20
cyberpatrouilleurs policiers en france
habilitée à faire ce que vous faites
c'est un travail nécessaire
à votre avis je pense que c'est un
travail d'intérêt public tous les
citoyens qui nous ont rejoint la team
ours et environ une cinquantaine de
personnes dans différents pays
le sait ces gens ont permis la formation
de plusieurs centaines de personnes à
travers le monde et la création de
différentes équipes
j remettent à leur tour un nombre
incalculable de dossiers dans différents
pays et dossiers qui sont judiciarise
abl des dossiers qui permette
l'ouverture d' enquête d'arrestation de
procès et de condamnation il faut savoir
qu'en france ce que nous faisons se base
sur l'article de loi le texte de loi 227
22,1 chitty que faire des propositions
sexuelles à un mineur ou à une personne
se présentant comme telle est un délit
passible de deux ans d'emprisonnement
cinquante six lits à 1 une rencontre à
la suite des échanges numériques
donc nous respectons scrupuleusement la
loi tous ces dossiers sont judiciarise
abl toutes ces équipes tous ces
bénévoles qui sont en train de soulever
peuvent maintenant inverser la tendance
changer le rapport de force
vous personnellement qu'est ce qui vous
anime à la veillée des défauts profil
d'enfants a animé à identifier de
présumés pédophiles pédophiles je suis
lanceurs d'alertés sur la question
depuis plus d'une décennie
sur la question de la paix de dix ans à
être spectateur de ça et finalement j'ai
juste voulu mettre au point une méthode
légale qui s'inspire des pratiques
anglaise où les groupes tels que les
nôtres sont à l'origine de la moitié
interpellation pédocriminels en
angleterre 50% des arrestations de
prédateurs sexuels d'enfants sont le
fait de citoyens comme vous et vous
voilà ce qui inspire ma démarche
finalement ma question ce que j'entende
les journalistes me demandent mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça ma
question à moi c'est pourquoi il n'y a
pas plus de monde qui fait ça voilà ma
question c'est c'est cette méthode
pourrait permettre de de révolutionner
la lutte ou call appel au cumul est
les anglais l'ont prouvé pourquoi les
français les suisses les belges et les
canadiens ne vous espérer un jour
travailler plus main dans la main avec
la police c'est ce que est ce qu un
cadre peut vous
ni ce qu'on demande depuis un an et demi
maintenant c'est ce qu'on a demandé à
travers différents médias différents
différentes voies c'est ce que nous
demandons depuis un an et demi nous
demandons la mise en place d'un cadre
légal pour travailler conjointement avec
les autorités
j'ai confronté fin de l'année dernière
emmanuel masson les yeux dans les yeux
qui a reconnu publiquement qu'ils
avaient besoin des lanceurs d'alerté que
nous et s'est engagé à la mise en place
d'un cadre légal il l'a dit devant tout
le pool des journalistes aucun média
français n'a jamais relayé l'information
sauf de médias jouent pour l'instant
vous n'avez rien vu venir
absolument pas puisque ils ont fait
marche arrière puisque au mois de
novembre il reconnaissait la légalité de
nous de nos méthodes nos pratiques et
maintenant quelques mois après ils
essayent de nous faire passer pour des
par la loi et criminel et invente des
textes de lois qui sont imaginaires
j'attends encore que quelle pme présente
le texte de loi qui disent que nous
sommes des hors la loi
au moment où je vous parle d un nombre
incalculable de prédateurs sexuels sont
identifiés en france les équipes sion
été créé sur le serveur révolution de
l'amour sont en mesure de remettre
plusieurs centaines de pédophile
français à la justice dès demain donc à
un moment donné il faudra que les
autorités prennent leurs responsabilités
pour acquis emmanuel macron prenne ses
responsabilités et s'est engagé sur la
mise en place d'un cadre légal
donc si ceux qui nous gouvernent ne font
rien pour protéger nos enfants
ils devront en porter pas responsables